my parents said I could be anything so I
became guy and when I'm up on stage I
feel like this is actually who I am my
name is Preston Thomas Martin and I'm a
bodybuilder the trans bodybuilding
competition is a bodybuilding
competition for trans men who are pre or
post op for their Top surgery it's
basically like a comfortable setting
that we can all come to those of us who
love fitness this is the third year of
the competition and it's grown a lot
since they first started there's more
competitors there's more people that are
coming out to see it it's just growing
bigger and bigger right I've always
watched the national professional
bodybuilders up on stage and I'm just
like oh man I want to be there one day
and this trans bodybuilding competition
has done that for trans people this is a
comfortable setting for me to do
something that I love to do and show off
I came to like bodybuilding because I
realized that it helped me a lot as far
as my mental health goals bodybuilding
is like therapy for me it helps me learn
how to calm myself it makes you a
stronger person all the way around after
transitioning my perspective on
masculinity has changed a lot even
though it's been six years since I've
been transitioning I am still sweetheart
when I look in the mirror now I see a
strong person but I have really had to
look at my life and everything that I
have accomplished and everything that I
have been through and been able to come
back from the fact that I am happy with
my transition I'm happy with the way
that I'm turning out in the way I'm
looking I'm happy with how strong I'm
becoming mentally I looking around I
can't help but smile I get excited
[Music]